subject of tax is that the whole area has been flooded in our house,
we are very worried, our houses have been
submerged and our houses have been broken, we face
a lot of trouble in going to school,
even the rescuers come to pick us up, tuition
Vaishampayan Nav, we leave this  Come
[Music]
I am one third of Pakistan and water right
now which has succeeded in every boundary Nobody knows that I worked
very hard on this We worked
hard and had high hopes
that we would get more benefits than we
spent  We would have benefited as much as we had done, but whatever
happened for a few days, whatever were our
hopes, whatever we had in our heart, let them
all be present and everything was
completely destroyed in the rain, nothing is left
[Music]
Because of the flood, so many  Naming has come
so that the goods cannot come to Balochistan in what amount. There is a
national bandh. Due to the flood, the
goods are being woven somewhere. Here too the
business week is completely over.
A man cannot feed his children
or pay the rent.  Neither
can you pay the electricity bill, everything is becoming double expensive,
when you tell a man to urinate, then disconnect here, when a
woman urinates, what will you do, nothing is a
problem, it's a problem, when
I ca
n't do this, it's
MP3
that  Houses should be built and see the wonders. Understand that due to the
rain, there is water in the house and the
whole place has collapsed. Look, there is
no hope left to build. Allah will give us
where to go. We all have
happened.